hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers from all
different disciplines
my guest today is guy raz at guy
raz r-a-z he is the creator and host of
the popular podcasts
how i built this wisdom from the top and
the rewind
on spotify he's also the co-creator of
the acclaimed podcast's
ted radio hour and the children's
program wow
in the world he is in a sense
the michael phelps of podcasters
at least according to a new york times
profile not long ago he is the only
person to ever have
three shows in the top 20 rankings
worldwide
simultaneously he's also received the
edward
r murrow award the daniel shore
journalism prize the national headliner
award
and the nabj award that is among many
others
and was a neiman journalism fellow at
harvard he lives in the bay area his new
book how i built this subtitle the
unexpected paths to success from the
world's most inspiring entrepreneurs
is out now you should check it out it is
an absolutely incredible compilation of
stories
and tactics past podcast guest adam
grant describes it as quote
this is an incredible quote quote the
mother of all entrepreneurship memoirs
it is a must read for anyone who wants
to start a business grow a business or
be inspired
by those who do that checks pretty much
all the boxes
you can find him online at guyroz.com
g-u-y-r-a-z dot com on twitter at gairaz
instagram guy dot
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e
i have had so much tea in my life i've
been to
china i've lived in china in japan i've
done tea tours i drink a lot of tea
and 10 years plus of physical
experimentation and tracking has shown
me many things
chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health
you name it i've been drinking fermented
poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now
poo air tea delivers more polyphenols
and probiotics than you can shake a
stick at it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to find
real poo air that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why
peaks fermented pure tea crystals have
become my daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them
through my friends dr peter atia and
kevin rose peak
crystals are cold extracted using only
wild harvested leaves from 250 year old
tea trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea
and i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a
a delicious barnyard very peaty if you
like whiskey and stuff like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic mold contaminants commonly found
in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea and that saves a
ton of time and hassle
so peak is offering 15 percent off their
puertes for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer
simply visit peaktee.com tim that's
p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners of this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is risk free
one more time check it out
peak t that's p i q u e e dot com
slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs small businesses have
unique needs
a lot of you know this i know this and
even with the uncertainty these days one
thing
stands unchanged and that is the
importance of having the right people
on your team but hiring can be hard it
can be really expensive if you make
mistakes
very painful if you get it wrong i've
certainly had that experience and i'm
not eager to repeat it so i try to do as
much
upfront screening as possible when your
business is ready to make the next hire
linkedin jobs can help you screen
candidates with the hard and soft skills
that you're looking for
they'll match your position with
qualified members so you can find the
right person
quickly using linkedin's active
community of more than 690 million
professionals worldwide
linkedin jobs can help you find and hire
the right person faster
so when your business is ready to make
that next hire find the right person
with linkedin jobs you can pay what you
want and get the first 50
off just visit linkedin.com
tim again that's linkedin.com tim to get
50
off your first job post terms and
conditions apply
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
[Music]
guy welcome to the show thanks so much
for having me
and i have so many questions so many
questions for you i've been really
looking forward to this
and i thought i would start with a very
important question and that is are you
willing to come to this interview and
surrender
100 yes i've surrendered
yes and that might seem
to my long-term listeners an odd place
for me to start
but as i understand it you frequently
asked your guests
that question and it seems like you are
a master of creating
safe spaces and i've i've read you
describe how i built this
as not a show about business but in a
sense a show about vulnerability so
what are some of the things that you've
found
helpful the things that you do to help
put interviewees at ease
i think the first the first thing i do
tim is i have a conversation with
everybody before they come on the show
months before they come on the show and
the reason why i do that is because
you know my show is not meet the press
we're not interrogating
politicians about public policy it's a
show about
someone's journey and
they don't have to come on the show it's
voluntary we don't want anybody to feel
forced that they're coming on the show
but i want everybody to understand
how we operate and so the first thing i
do
when i um when we reach out to somebody
is we we set up a time for us to talk
and i basically say then look
this is going to be really different
from most of the interviews you do
because
a it's going to be long and b
there's no preconditions i'm going to
know as much about you
as i can possibly know because we will
have done a really deep dive research
profile on you and
you have to be willing to talk about
everything and
unless it's you know something that was
very personal like a divorce or
or something like that that's not really
relevant but in general
what i say is that you know everything's
on the table because a human story is a
360 degree story
and if we're just talking about the
facebook highlight reel of your life
it's not going to be an honest
conversation and and our audience is not
going to connect to you
and you will be doing yourself a
disservice and that that's really kind
of how
how i start the process and then you
know when we have the conversation
several weeks later we've already had
that kind of
interaction and encounter so that's kind
of the first
thing that i do before i sit down with
somebody and
if we double click on the research
profile and more broadly speaking just
prep
for a given episode if you reflect back
and maybe it's
somewhat standardized i would imagine
you have some some processes that have
been
refined to best practices over time but
what does the
prep look like how do you build a
research profile there's so many
different ways
to approach this i'd be very curious to
hear you expand on that
i mean i have been in journalism my
whole life
um i started out as a reporter when i
was 22.
and basically the job you know the job
of a reporter is to become an
instant expert reporters really are
dilatants right
we we don't have a um you know we don't
have a phd in a very narrow subject but
but good reporters learn a lot about a
subject very quickly
you have to be able to do that you know
when i was a reporter i would be sent
to macedonia because there was a
flare-up in a conflict
and i would have 24 hours to get there
and i would rush to a bookstore and buy
everything i could
about macedonia and the balkans and
start to read
it's similar with interviewing the
people who come on the show
obviously i have a team that helps me
gather all that information
but depending on on who the person is if
they've written a book i will have read
the book
if they have been around a long time
there's usually a lot of material
we do a really extensive background
search and check on the person
for both public information and even
non-public information
and it's really designed to make sure
that we can contextualize any you know
someone's story
we want to know everything about them
and everything about their business and
in their lives because lives are complex
so sometimes we come across
things that you know that are not public
that
maybe might be a little bit embarrassing
and we'll you know we'll talk about it
um you know on the phone first and and
kind of talk through
how we're gonna tackle that thing could
you give an example
of what non-public might be and how you
find it i assume it's not a dick tracy
trench coat wearing character following
somebody around
can you give an example of non-public so
there was an an entrepreneur who i
really wanted to interview it was a
wonderful story
and had had a phone call with this
entrepreneur
um a really interesting category um
brand
and um it was you know we we had this
call and
it was a good conversation and then once
we started to do some research we
we discovered that this entrepreneur
actually
had spent some time in jail for
securities fraud in the 1980s
okay this was not in any of the public
profiles or articles that we read about
this person
so we called this person back up and i'm
being obviously deliberately
vague we called this person back up and
i said look you know we came across this
this story that clearly when you were a
younger person
you committed securities fraud or were
convicted of it and spent
some time in jail you know we're going
to have to talk about this
and you know hopefully you can kind of
address it and say you know i was stupid
and young and greedy or whatever it
might be
but you know in in context i think it'll
be really interesting for people to hear
about
about it and about your life and about
the decisions you made and what you
learned from that
and this person said i will not talk
about that i refuse to discuss that
and that was that's fine i said i
completely respect that
when you're ready to talk about it let
me know and we'll we'll do the episode
with you so we did not in the end have
that person on the show
but then you know you've got people like
you know like steve madden
who went to jail for you know the the
shoemaker who went to jail for two years
also for security strut and was really
open
to talk about it and what he learned
about it and how that changed his life
and shaped who he is
because as he told me on the show you
know he was greedy he got really greedy
at a certain point in his life he was in
a bad place he was
high on coke um and he committed fraud
you know
um went to jail for two years but really
kind of turned his life around
and to actually become a prison reform
activist so
i i think that that i'm not looking for
angels or mother teresa's no no one is
like that i'm not like that
um but i'm looking for people to to put
their life stories in context so
so that's when we you know that's that
that happens sometimes
because we really do spend a lot of time
diving into
the stories of the people who come on
the show and and by the way
what i i sometimes joke with people who
come on the show tim
which is i say you know when i interview
you there's a good chance i will know
more about your life than than you even
know at that moment because it's so
fresh in my mind
you know because people will talk about
their stories and in the in the process
of
uh being interviewed they'll sometimes
say well it's 1996 and
you know it was the first time i made a
sale and i know that it happened in 1995
and i will stop them they'll say
hey just to interrupt you it actually
happened in 95. can you
can you say that and they'll say really
and because you know we we
want the sh we want the show it is a
single person's narrative
and a single narrative oral history is
always going to be problematic you know
we
we don't have multiple voices on a
documentary there aren't multiple voices
who can weigh in
so we try to play the role me and my
team we try to
play the role of making sure that it is
factually correct
and fair to all the people whose voices
are not represented
in the episode thank you that makes
sense i want to
ask a question and i'm sure there will
be more about how i built this
and i'm going to frame this maybe in an
unusual way
in the reading that i've done you seem
to be a very self-effacing guy
so i'm going to comment this obliquely
how would
your wife explain why or how
how i built this became as popular as it
has become
i'll take a crack at it um on her behalf
probably probably my perspective will
come into it um
i think it became i here's here's what i
would say
i had a show called the ted radio hour
which is still around it's a terrific
show
and you were on it actually i've
interviewed i had you on it and that was
really just an amazing experience to be
able to develop that show
i got very lucky tim i rode
the podcast wave very early so ted radio
hour was launched in 2013
and podcasting really started to take
off with
cereal with that show serial you know
your podcast probably even even saw a
rise right all podcasts that were around
saw a rise and so
you know all of a sudden ted radio hour
you know with the the combination of the
ted brand the npr brand and then just
podcasting rising and
look i think we made a really high
quality show it's still a terrific show
um we we got a big audience you know we
all of a sudden had millions of people
listening to the show every month and
sort of on the strength of that how i
built this was a side project
it was it was never intended to be what
it became really it was
let me put this out into the world and
see if there's interest i
and i should say i should add to the
caveat that i'm not
you know i am an entrepreneur i've i've
started businesses
but i'm not richard branson i'm not tim
ferriss you know i'm for most of my
god the world doesn't need two of those
but i mean you're
you know you've you you are kind of a
model for a lot of entrepreneurs and
i i for most of my career as a
journalist and there's
entrepreneurial things you have to be
and do to be journalists but that was
what i did for most of my career
and for me how i built this was
really an extension of what i was doing
which was telling stories
and to me the idea of
like a great story like great film has
just a clear arc right you've probably
read joe you probably read joseph
campbell's work when you were in college
and know about you know the hero's
journey right and just listening to the
power of myth interview series with bill
moyers
in the last few weeks okay so you right
and and how george lucas
use this to make star wars and it's an
amazing concept that
every story has a roughly the same
narrative arc it's whether it's
gilgamesh or
the odyssey or harry potter and joseph
campbell kind of codifies this and
i felt like in with
business and brands and the building of
something big you can kind of trace
elements of that journey you know
there's the abyss
the trough of sorrow whatever people
call it you know the sled you slay the
dragon you almost die
you find a mentor i mean you return to
the village it's all
bits of those archetypes are found in
in stories about business and so i
really wanted to figure out a way to
tell
hero's journey stories and by the way i
could do that
i think you could do that with athletes
you know you could do that with other
in other categories but i just thought
business would be interesting but i
didn't
you know we didn't like when you started
your show probably like we didn't test
market it we didn't
do a bunch of advanced research we just
put it out there
and kind of you know
just said let's see what happens and
i think like a lot of things that become
successful
our great success was word of mouth you
know
um i mean obviously there's some
built-in advantages which which is
the show is distributed by npr which is
a huge podcast
company and platform but i think it's a
you know as a combination of
um hearing really deep dramatic stories
and hearing them told in a cinematic way
you know the the show really
we designed the show to be very visual
that it's a journey
and i think people just started to
connect with those stories even people
who were not into business
people who were just just kind of needed
a shot in the arm
you know that day or that week and
that's really how it started to get
popular and here we are today so i mean
i i'm not trying to sound
falsely modest here but i really i was
very surprised
at how successful and popular it became
i really was
i want to add a few observations that
may or may not
be true but they're i guess speculation
i think the show
also benefits from
a in a sense a singular focus
that is well conveyed in a tightly
curated format
with a prescriptive title right it it
has
focus in a an ocean
of flotsam and jetsam in the sense that
there are many podcasts
one might even say my podcast included
that can really meander all over the
place
and i think that with how i built this
people are able to ascertain immediately
whether or not they are interested just
by looking at the thumbnail
and that is i think a rarity in the
world of podcasting i do think that
there's the and it's it's not just the
the
face of the podcast that is the book
cover but
the way that you as you described
take a story and create something that
is emotionally compelling with the touch
points
the archetypes these stages in the
heroes journey
that are immediately subconsciously
recognizable and strike a chord
with people who are listening it's it's
so reliable
yeah i think people hear those stories
and they think that's me
i'm just like that person like like like
jamie simenoff who founded ring you know
he he was the kid who used to take apart
radios and televisions and build his own
radio controlled cars and had a frog
like
do you remember the frog that
radio-controlled car
yeah he like you know he was that kid
who's going to the
to the like hobby shop and building his
own kits um
and i think people hear these stories
and they think or they hear stacey brown
of chicken salad chick who started
a restaurant empire of chicken salad you
know selling chicken salad door-to-door
um they hear these stories and they
think they're not superheroes
you know they're they're not any
different at a certain point in their
life
nobody would take their call everyone
takes stuart butterfield's call today
but not at the beginning you know even
howard schultz not at the beginning
and that's what i'm trying to convey and
i think that's also
how people connect with this idea and by
the way the name how i built this
originally i've actually never
talked about this not to keep it a
secret but i've no one's asked me about
it i never
i just you just reminded me of it but
originally i was gonna call the show
the hustle okay
because i thought in 2015 when i started
working on this
that that was more propulsive you know i
wanted
how i built this to be kind of like the
anti-npr you know npr has this
reputation right this kind of almost
asmr
kind of way of sounding right you know
like
these um people say oh the dulcet tones
of npr
you know like this is npr and
the reality is there is some of that
right um
and but but the reality is there's a lot
of npr that doesn't sound like that
you know that i have to just pause for a
second
if people don't know the acronym that
you refer to
google it we're going to move on but
please continue um
you know it's like this is npr but the
thing is is that a lot of npr programs
don't sound like that and you might not
hear them because they might just be
podcasts you know like code switch
or planet money or or the shows that i
do
and i wanted this to be like almost
the encounter to what npr sounds like i
wanted the theme song to be like i i
wanted the theme song of the show
in fact ramtina or bluey who wrote the
theme song and was my first producer now
has his own show on npr
wonderful show called throughline he was
a dj i had met him
and i was looking for a freelance
producer to help me launch this show he
knew nothing about radio and i just
loved him he was just the nicest person
i ever met so anyway
he came in and did a temp gig with me
and that's how he launched the show and
then he became
my first producer but i said he's also a
composer so i said
i want the theme song to sound like this
song by beck
it's the first song off the album i'm
blinking now i'll have to look it up
but it's a song by beck and i i said i
want i want this
set this propulsive sound to inspire
what you write and
so he wrote this song and it's fair it's
like
so you know it was really like very very
different than the morning edition theme
right like
um very kind of propulsive and almost in
your face
and so i thought the hustle you know
it's the hustle and
um i just thought it was a great title i
thought it was going to be so
you know that's the that was really how
i just i was so
wanted a title so bad and then we did
some uh a legal check and
determined that it was not a good idea
that we would run into some challenges
with
other shows this hustle that hustle so
i went back to the drawing board i said
all right how i built this which
actually was
one of the names i thought of but i i
thought it was kind of a boring name
but i mean it turned out to be the right
name because
imagine if me who is like
you know has the show called the hustle
you know it
just is so not me and so not what the
show is
and and how i built this was really kind
of like the boring
sort of okay we'll do that one but it
turned out to be the right decision and
so sometimes things happen for a reason
so how i built this simple you know what
the show is about although in the in the
beginning
some people did wonder whether it was a
show about like a home depot show like
building things so we've managed to
overcome that
the literalism and the internet are uh
frequent bedfellows
it's hard to avoid a little bit of that
and i have an embarrassing
confession to make which is my initial
title for the four hour work week which
one could very compellingly argue still
sounds like an infomercial product you'd
see it two in the morning but
the title of the book in the book
proposal that was
that was shopped around was lifestyle
hustling also vetoed
for non-trademark reasons yes
so you you're you and we have been
talking
about how i built this you often
cover pivots of different types critical
decisions that are made to change
direction in the
context of an entrepreneur's life or a
company and
i want to ask you about what seems to be
a pivot in your own life and
it seems like this happened around 2012
and this is a leading question so please
feel free to rewrite the question
but i'll read a little bit here from and
this is on a site that i did not expect
to have as a source but
ylai ylai.state.gov which has full
interview with kairaz
but it begins with this little excerpt
news reporters by training and tradition
i think identify problems without
talking about solutions and in general
the profession frowns on solutions based
reporting and it goes on
and then it talks about where i say
quotes you are saying i think for me the
real turning point was in 2012 it was an
election year there was a lot of
division within the u.s i was hosting a
news magazine
on npr and then the year culminated with
the new town shootings
and for me that was it i was done with
the news at that point can you
talk about my understanding is then
that's when you really shifted into
focusing
on ted radio hour this seems
at least based on the research to
potentially be really
important this period could you speak to
that i'll talk about newtown first
because it's the hardest thing for me to
talk about and then i'll come back to
the other part
i'm a parent i've got an eleven-year-old
and a nine-year-old
and that the day that shooting happened
i was asked to host our national live
coverage
and it was one of the hardest things
i've done in my life
now i've covered five wars i've seen
human beings dead i saw humans
die before my eyes i never got near
newtown i never went there
i never saw it but it was so difficult
for me it was um
this intense feeling of sadness
and despair i remember reading um an
interview with president obama
after he left office and he said that
was actually the hardest day of his
presidency and i i still think about
that day i
it's hard it's just hard you know um
because
because i've got kids and um i just
think about those parents
um and that was sort of the
end for me i mean it was really building
up for a while
um i was getting tired of of how
news organizations do news i'm still
tired of it
i think most news organizations forever
and ever
thought that there was something called
objectivity
and that they determined what that was
and it was usually
older uh white men nothing wrong with
older white men i'm
you know i'm just saying it's just that
determined what objectivity was
and that we were basically we needed to
think of ourselves as robots as
automatons who had no
feelings or views or thoughts about the
world we were just there to deliver the
news
and if you asked most reporters and even
to this day if you ask a lot of
reporters in washington they will say
look all i do is call balls and strikes
that's my job
but i never thought that that was my job
that's not why
i wanted to be a journalist i wanted to
be a journalist because
i probably naively believed and still
believe
that the more knowledge people have
about other people the more people know
about
other people's stories it's more likely
that that
will make that person more empathetic
and i always thought if i went overseas
and i lived overseas and was a reporter
for many years if i went overseas and
told
those stories about people
who were living in war zones or conflict
zones or
who had no control over the process or
the conflict happening around them
if i could tell those stories then i
could make a contribution to
better human understanding i was not
going to do that on my own obviously i
was not
personally going to change the world but
i think many people
want to do something that will have an
impact on the world in a small way
and for me my small way was to be a
reporter
and to tell stories and when i was the
host of all things considered
by the time i i became the host of that
show in 2009
you know i i had a hard time
delivering the news in a way that needed
to be delivered because
there were just so many stories that
on the face of it just seemed totally
absurd
and wrong and false i mean and the way i
mean even the way
these organizations covered you know the
rise of the tea party for example as if
it was
you know this grassroots populist
anti-government movement of people who
wanted you know no deficits and no debt
i mean
that was nonsense we know that today we
know that so much of that was
propped up and influenced by huge
multi-billionaire
mega donors to these organizations with
names like freedom works and
you know whatever and they very
methodically kind of
organized this so-called movement
that eventually resulted in the election
that we had in 2016
but you know it's just a small example
of how we
me and my colleagues in the news media
really just bent over backwards to be
be so objective that you don't
call things out when they need to be
called out and i think that there are
long-term
consequences for doing that so in my
view
i felt like if i was going to make a
difference if i
if i really got into this profession to
make a difference in the world
it wasn't going to be through telling
the news you know i i had spent
at that point by the time i left in 2012
15 years as a reporter and
i didn't feel like the the world was
getting any better i
i felt like especially in our country is
getting more polarized
you know i felt like people were angrier
and angrier it's even worse today
that was 2012 and so you know it was a
kind of a culmination of things in my
mind where i thought
i need to figure out how to do what i
originally wanted to do with my life and
my career
but in a different way and that's really
what kind of led me to
to leap at the chance to collaborate
with ted to produce the ted radio hour
and create that show
um which which is how i kind of left the
news world
i'd love to explore some of your
influences what are the factors that
have perhaps
helped shape you in a way or what are
the things that might just indicate
the convictions and principles that that
guide you
and i'm probably gonna butcher the
pronunciation of this also
but a book that popped up there's one
you have read repeatedly
is homage to catalonia am i getting that
pronunciation
catalonia yeah homage there we go i'm
putting a faux french spin on it
but homage no homage am i getting this
right well i'm i'm really out
reading there's different there's
different pronunciations i always say
homage to catalonia yeah
very very forgiving by george orwell
could you
describe for people who don't know this
book
what it is and and why it has
made an impact on you i mean george
orwell is a really
complicated figure i should say at the
outset you know um
there are writings of his that are um
certainly racist
and anti-semitic um and
are and they're problematic but by the
time he died he was sort of seen as a
champion for
you know against imperialism and um you
know
anti-racism and and so on and so forth
putting that to one side for a moment um
george orwell who i think in some ways
is
um some some things about him are
overrated and i think sometimes he tends
to be over
venerated in part because the late
great incredible christopher hitchens
wrote so much about george orwell and
hitchens
was such an important public
intellectual in the united states and
really around the world and people had
so much respect and admiration for him
that you know that
he he really elevated george orwell but
george orwell was a
was a leftist um he was a committed
you know leftist who went to fight in
spain with the republicans to fight
against the fascists
and uh the the rough outline of the
story is that
you know the republicans were basically
social socialists right like social
democrats who wanted a
who had this utopian vision for spain
that was
free and fair and equitable
and progressive a light unto the world
right
but they were facing this very powerful
foe
in the fascists led by franco backed by
the nazis
in the mid-30s and the republicans were
backed by the communists by the soviet
communists
and what what happened very rapidly was
a split between
the communists and the republicans um
split is not exactly the right way to
describe it but essentially
orwell got there and he discovered that
there was an
internecine war between these two
left-wing movements
you know which was that one left-wing
movement wasn't pure and left enough
for the extreme left movement the
communist movement
and he came there with this idealism to
fight against
fascism and to unite
all of these you know groups on the left
to defeat this
you know this incredibly evil force and
became so disillusioned at the cynicism
that he saw
on his own side not to turn him into a
right winger he was he was a leftist his
whole life
but it was um it's it's just a story
about
purity and the false promises of purity
and that the world is full of nuance and
it's
full of contradictions and to me
that is what it means to be human
i mean i i admire people and respect
people who have strong held views
do you remember george bush used to talk
about you know his certitude
and and i have respect for george bush
as a human being not super supportive of
his politics but
um i don't believe in certitude i i
actually
really believe that at least for me
that i'm open to having my my views
changed you know i i welcome that i'm
i'm constantly interrogating
how i feel about the world and the
things i think
about the world you know i was reading
about like bayesian analysis you know
that this idea that
you know the last thing you think that
you've read or you you know about
you know becomes sort of in your mind it
naturally becomes like the thing that
you believe or is the most present and
beijing and analysts
are constantly interrogating what they
believe to come to
a fuller understanding of a subject you
know epidemiologists talk about this a
lot
and i love that idea i love the idea
that i can talk to somebody who may know
a lot about a topic or subject or an
issue
and can really convince me that the way
i think about it is wrong
or that maybe i should rethink it and
that's
that to me is what that book speaks to
the the there's another
version of that book which i i've
recently reread
and really recommend that people read
called darkness at noon
by arthur kessler um also written in um
around that time
in 1941 i believe and it was about the
soviet trials the stalinist trials of
the 1930s
and you know you read that book and you
realize that
the soviet union really wasn't ever
very for just a very brief period of
time was it truly a socialist
country in the ideals of what socialism
were meant to be it was a dictatorship
it was
i mean there were very few differences
between
you know stalinism the fascism of
stalinism and the fascism of any other
fascist
state i mean it was a police state it
was filled with terror
it was filled with paranoia so
you know unfortunately it gets kind of
conflated with socialism but it
you know you read that book and you you
realize that you know
um that when humans
pursue purity when they pursue
you know these ideals of purity it can
really lead to
disaster and that's why i love those
books because as a reporter
as an interviewer as a person you know
i'm
always looking to have my views change
i'm always open to it i want to learn
from people
that's why i do it's why you do what you
do you know we do this because
for free we get to learn from other
people
and what a gift that is you know to know
that
on any given day my my whole world can
be blown apart you know
and how exciting is that talk about a
specific
it is exciting and i agree that the
in some way the i'm not going to call it
a fool's errand but it's
maybe faustian bargain is a better way
to look at it the the
search for pristine truth
is not just sometimes but usually leads
to disaster in one form or another right
because it creates these
incredible blind spots yeah and
uh freedom fighters can become tyrants
very quickly
uh when they begin to look at things in
a binary yeah i mean look at that
no flexibility excellent example
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on
percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you
at an incredibly low cost wealthfront
software constantly monitors your
portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
let's talk about how your views have
changed as it relates to
your own experience of depression you've
been quite public about this uh it seems
like you related to it differently
when you were younger at least compared
to perhaps how you
speak about it now or could you tell us
more about your
experience with depression and relating
to depression
well first thing i would say about it
tim is that i know you've talked about
it too
is that it is it's not
for me it doesn't feel courageous to
talk about it
now because i have
you know i'm i'm i i'm in a privileged
position
i have these shows and i have a platform
so i don't think that talking about
depression from my perspective
is courageous i talk about it because i
want younger
people and even people who aren't
younger to understand that
it is not strange you are not
broken you're not you know they're all
these things that
i think people who are under
experiencing depression um
think about and go through you know and
i remember feeling
selfish like how could you feel this way
you know
how could you be so self-absorbed i
would say things to myself that
that i remember just feeling horrible
about feeling horrible
you know um and totally and i remember
when i was um
i mean when i was in my early 20s i
i was sort of i think like a lot of
young people
um wasn't quite sure how to
navigate my life i think it's much much
more acute today even i mean i'm 45 i
think it's much more acute today among
young people
than even when we were in our 20s when i
think about it now what i realize is
that
throughout our lives most of us have a
safety net
you know if we're lucky enough to to
have that we we have school
elementary school and middle school and
high school
and if you know and then we go on to
college and there are people cheering us
on and there's always a safety net you
always know what's going to happen the
next year you're going to go to
grade 11 or become a sophomore or junior
and people are cheering you on and and
you're you know you're in college and
you're doing some interesting things you
might be on the student newspaper you
might organize a club or you might have
belonged to a an activist group and you
have an identity you know people know
you oh there's tim
he's the social justice activist or
there's
guy he's the newspaper writer and then
you finish and you're expected to be an
adult
you're 22 in a lot of cases and your
whole life has already is kind of been
mapped out but then
that safety that's gone and
i think when you combine that with all
of the
changes that are probably happening not
probably that are
happening in our brains between the ages
of 18 and 29
it's a recipe for depression anxiety
you know that when we were in our 20s
we didn't know as much about how the
human brain develops as we do now
we we now know that the human brain the
executive functions of the human brain
continue to develop
until our late 20s early 30s that the
brain is not fully
formed there's a lot sloshing around in
there
and you combine that with you know these
circumstances
of entering life without a a net all of
a sudden
and it's not surprising that a lot of
young people experience anxiety
depression and in my case
it hit me like a train you know i was
outwardly you know things seemed okay i
was
starting my career at npr and just
pounding the pavement and writing for
the washington city paper and
trying to um you know get my articles
published and
but inside i was a mess you know um
and and i couldn't explain it to myself
i couldn't understand what was happening
and i couldn't talk about it with
anybody because
i grew up in a house where
that was mental health was not seen as a
real thing
that it was lunacy that
you know that didn't there was no such
thing as mental illness i think a lot of
people can relate to that you know
now of course we we talk about it a bit
more but you know
back then um you know when when i was
growing up in the 80s and 90s
people had mental health issues were
seen as crazy and you just didn't talk
about it
and for me you know it really began to
culminate in just not getting out of bed
and not coming to work
and calling in sick and making excuses
for not going in and
you know my around age 24 i was in
really
really just bad desperate shape i didn't
know what to do i felt
trapped in my body and also immobilized
and i
i couldn't talk to anybody about it
because i was embarrassed also
i was really embarrassed and ashamed um
and just
really wanted to just die
you know i i really i remember
feeling that so acutely that it would
just be so
great if i didn't wake up you know and
i was very fortunate at that time
to have a very important mentor
who to this day is my closest friend
and she had
experienced her own mental health issues
and so she she came to check in on me
and
um my apartment in washington dc
she knew something wasn't wrong and
she made an appointment for me with a
doctor to go see
a doctor a psychologist a psychiatrist
forgive me
and i began to talk to him
for several sessions and spend about
five years on antidepressants
so um and now i will i will say this
i don't know if the antidepressants
were effective i hope i don't sound like
tom cruise but the jury is out on
whether
ssris are actually effective and right
this is a real legitimate debate in
in psychiatry but i will say that
knowing that i was
actually i think that the knowledge that
i was
trying to regain control over myself
helped a lot and you know the five years
that i used
antidepressants helped me immensely
because
whether they it was a prophylactic
effect or not that it helped
and it enabled me to to kind of
live a relatively normal life and what i
think has really been remarkable is
for me is that it doesn't leave
you know if you've given me depression
the dark dog the black dog it's gonna
come back
but i find that as i've gotten older
it becomes immensely more manageable
and that's the difference is that
you learn to accept that
it will happen it will pop up
and as i have gotten older
and have been able to reflect on it more
i've also learned how to manage and cope
and kind of self-heal you know and
that's been i think that's
really an important thing that i try and
talk to younger people because i'm i try
to make myself
available to interns at npr or younger
people that i come across who
are scared to talk about it or
embarrassed and i'm just like i've been
there you know and
but i want you to know that as you get
older it will become more manageable
and you will get it it will happen again
but it's it's not going to be quite as
intense or quite as
difficult if you start to work through
it now
thank you so much for sharing uh as you
know this is a
subject that's uh near and dear to me in
a sense
and i'd love to ask you a few follow up
questions
the first i suppose actually just a
comment first
which is uh to add to your
your point of management becoming easier
as you get older i've been reading a
fair amount of
the writing of anthony demelo who was a
he's since passed but he was a jesuit
priest
and also a psychotherapist and
his number of books awareness another is
rediscovering
life so fairly generic titles but the
content some of the content i find to be
very very helpful and one of the
anecdotes that stuck with me from the
latter
which is a very fast read the beginning
of rediscovering life is quite
lukewarm but the anecdote
was a description of this
enlightened being let's call it a a monk
and the monk says before enlightenment i
was depressed
after enlightenment i'm still depressed
but the way that i relate to the
depression is different
and that makes all the difference and
for me
that really touches on the crux
of things but i i want to just because
i've had a lot of experience with this
and you mentioned ted i mean that was my
my ted talk was on
management of this but you said that you
got off of antidepressants
or you were on them for five years how
did you make the decision to come off of
them
and and why it wasn't really a momentous
decision it wasn't like um you know a
moment where i [ __ ] i smashed a
champagne bottle against the side of a
ship you know it was um
it it was very it was just sort of like
you know i think i'm going to try this
and you know i wasn't um seeing a
a therapist i mean at the time you know
this five-year period
when i was taking antidepressants i mean
this was when i
i covered the iraq war i covered the war
in afghanistan
i became the cnn correspondent
covering palestine and israel um
i was you know in and out of iraq and
embedding with the military
you have a goat slaughtered in your
honor right
i mean i was i was constantly on the
move
which i think also probably had a a huge
impact on
on my ability to cope because i was
racing and racing and racing around
a lot you know um and it was really just
it kind of
let me try this out and it was fine i
will say
that when that ended when i stopped
being a foreign correspondent i came
back to the united states
and i came back to npr because i left
npr went to cnn
and then i went back to npr i i went
right back into a depression um very
quickly i mean it was
sometimes more intense sometimes less
intense
and part of that was because i think i
wasn't racing around i wasn't hopping on
planes all the time i was back
in washington dc kind of
trying to figure out what i was going to
do at npr
and then i started to cover the pentagon
for a while and it was
really hard and dull and challenging for
me
personally um and you know there was a
moment
in that time period where
it was about 2007 where i really
thought okay i'm kind of done with this
profession you know that that this is
really not
i don't really have a future here in
part because i really wanted to
transition
from being a reporter which i i wasn't
happy doing
and i didn't think i was very good at it
i was fine i was perfectly fine i just i
wasn't
you won a hell of a lot of awards for
somebody who wasn't very good at it yeah
but you know the thing about awards
awards are nonsense i mean
i'm i'm being totally i mean awards are
people who get awards are people who
submit their work
right so that's the first thing you
gotta submit your work
the second thing is um you know very few
awards
are really you know awarded in a
in a you know i mean the pulitzer's have
committees and
some of these bigger rewards have you
know lots of communities where the
people really do
carefully read or most awards are
are kind of handed out so just
yes i have those awards and i'm thank
you for the people giving them to me
but um take them with a grain of salt so
that being said
um i really wanted to i felt like i
wanted to have bigger
conversations like this one you know i
wanted to be able to talk to
a wide range of people and i really
wanted to
to host programs and at the time um
i was told that i was not i did not have
the right personality to be a radio host
how is that presented to you what what
does that mean yeah i mean
i'm not i'm not questioning the
statement i'm just wondering how that
was
expressed to you what was lacking or
wrong with your personality for radio
i was too
much of a military war correspondent if
you can believe that nobody
who hears how i built this today would
even knows that i did that
but that was how i was perceived and i
think this is very common in
in a lot of you know for a lot of people
that they are
they work somewhere and there's a
perception that's developed around them
or about them and it's hard to shake
that
you know sometimes the only way to shake
that is to leave and in my case
i that was my reputation um you know and
i was seen as like a very
serious and you know an npr host had to
be
you know like a a vaudevillian actor and
and i didn't have you know
whatever it was whatever the people
tones you didn't have the dull set tones
but but i was told that i just didn't
have the right
personality for that and um and i
i don't think that was an unfair
assessment at the time
i think that i wish that the person who
told me that who was
pretty important at the time would have
given me a shot to prove myself
but i don't think it was an unfair
assessment based on the work i was doing
you know so really at that time i
began to think about what else could i
do with my life you know
i was married still am we did not yet
have a child
but we knew we wanted one and and i
started to just kind of flail and look
around and that that was also a very
tough period
what kind of saved me was um and what
has
saved me throughout my career was always
trying to re
figure out how to regain control you
know of the situation and in that case
it was um applying for the neiman
fellowship i applied for a bunch of
different
fellowships and i got the neiman
fellowship it's a journalism fellowship
at harvard
where they bring in you go there for a
year and they give you
free tuition and you get a stipend for
housing
and you can do whatever you want and
that was a transformational year
you know that's really that's when i
first was exposed to
the case study method um which
inspired high abilities no kidding yeah
i didn't know that
how that makes perfect sense that's when
i you know that's when i first
took a class at the business school and
we got the case studies and i was just
fastest this is how they teach business
school through stories
this is incredible i mean that planted
the seed in my mind for how i built this
i started to host shows on wbur in
boston that year
and that really was a transformational
year so then when i
finished that year i came out of the
nieman fellowship with a child
we had a child he was born my oldest son
now henry
transformational here and um and i
became the host of all things considered
on the weekend
and so that really you know that was a
real turning point for me but
you know in the time before that i
really did kind of return to that
dark place um trying to kind of figure
out
my life and trying to wrestle with the
demons in my head and
um you know eventually it passed again
you seem to also have a very well a a
combination
of prolific output and
a solid seemingly from the outside sort
of identity
as the the sort of heir apparent podcast
king
in many respects at least in the minds
of a lot of people
and i'd love to somewhat along those
lines
ask just a little bit more about the the
fellowship so the neiman journalism
fellowship at harvard transformational
year
how much of that was seeing the case
studies and so on which are fantastic
and people can for those people
listening who are interested find i
believe harvard business school hbs
case studies as well as stanford
business school case studies
uh online you can you can actually
access some of these
outstanding how much of it was the
content
versus the break versus the ability to
breathe
with a concrete answer to
what are you or what do you do i'm a
neiman journalism fellow at harvard
versus something else i'm just i'd love
to hear you speak a little bit more
about
why that was so transformational it was
transformational
because i had been in the news world
my whole professional life and anyone
who has been
in one industry or in one place knows
what it's like to
develop tunnel vision you know you are
around
people who think like you in general and
who have similar interests now
journalists are
fascinating wonderful people i love
journalists they're they're some of the
most
interesting funniest smartest people
around
but you know the news business and news
organizations
especially npr are extremely
conservative culturally and very slow to
change you know things that that are
radical at news organizations in the
business world
people would be like why why is that
radical like what do you
what do you mean like that's what we do
every day you're telling that's a big
deal you know
because news organizations operate with
their own set of standards and
guidelines
and values that sometimes make a lot of
sense and sometimes don't
and that year just tore those blinders
off
all of a sudden i'm i'm i'm out of my
environment and i recommend this to
so many people i say when you're stuck
in life figure out a way to just get out
for a month or a year or six months and
just as a digression
i did an episode on la colombe coffee
right you have you had la collum coffee
before
i have i have so i did i did an episode
of how i built this on these guys
and you know you know one of the
co-founders
he basically like he was going through a
depression
when they were trying to form the
company todd carmichael and
he wanted to just drop out and leave and
his co-founder said just take some time
just go and todd like
flew to a remote island in the south
pacific
with no electricity and in for a penny
in for a pound yeah
and lived there for three months he
basically he basically did what you do
what you used to do for your books but
like to actually experiment on yourself
but he did this
you know because he had to to survive
and he went out there and he lived there
for three months
he fished and he he had no communication
the outside world
but it completely transformed his mind
you know and i
for me that was a kind of a much more
comfortable version of that
going to cambridge massachusetts and
getting to take classes at the harvard
business school and the law school and
the college and
but it it just it re awakened me
you know you know how um and it was that
plus
you know becoming a father for the first
time and and i think
what that really helped me also to
become
strangely enough was less cynical you
know there is a
a natural skepticism that you develop as
a journalist which i think is important
but oftentimes that develops into
cynicism
many journalists are just cynical and
i had some of that and i needed to get
away
to lose that i would never have you know
if i was a journalist and i heard about
the harvard business school case studies
i would have been like oh yeah a bunch
of
you know business people making more
money or something i would have
i don't know if that's what i would have
said but it would have been something
closer to that
but getting away from that world you
know 12 13 years ago
and seeing it a completely different
world for a year
kind of just re-awakened me it was like
i was just able to chip away and then
really start to
push away that cynicism just really push
it away
and start to kind of it's like i was
able to relax to like dance you know
i mean i i say dance but you know i was
one of those kids in high school who
would sit on the
on the sides you know on the sidelines
and the walls during the dances because
i thought
the people were dancing weren't cool you
know even though i wasn't cool i just
i didn't you know what i mean but that
year really kind of made me see
the world in a different way because i
was outside of my own environment
and that was so important for me and
that's really how
you know how i was able to to see things
and just to comp
through completely different lenses
let's talk about the patterns that
you've spotted i i really am dying to
ask
first though about i'm still
i'm still envisioning this island in the
middle of the ocean with no outside
communication
which could be the greatest blessing of
your life or i mean i'm getting
sort of pangs of anxiety just thinking
about it what effect did that have on
this entrepreneur
on todd yeah i mean it yeah he he spent
three months
um three months is a long time yeah yeah
in a very in a remote place with no
electricity no cell service this is in
the
1990s you know um he wrote a novel which
has never been published he says it was
cathartic he says a terrible novel but
he wrote it um he got a lot out
you know he wrote a lot of his head out
onto paper
um and i know you do this a lot i know
you you're into journaling and
writing things down can be incredibly
incredibly important especially when
you're experiencing anxiety and just as
an aside
about six months ago no it's maybe nine
months ago
i was going through just i had a lot of
anxiety i was working on this book and
i was like i had all these deadlines and
live shows and i've got my kids show
out in the world and how i built this
and i was you know leaving ted radio
hour
and that transition was happening and i
just had a lot of anxiety
and i couldn't sleep and it was like one
in the morning and my wife
was up and she's like look she grabs a
journal from the side of the bed she
says just start telling me what's on
your mind
and she wrote everything down she just
bullet pointed every
single thing oh she she she did it for
me you dictated i just amazed it
that's a good one i'm gonna close this
up
okay now go to sleep and we looked at
that three months later and not a single
thing on that list mattered
nothing on that list mattered it was you
know things that just seemed
insurmountable none of them mattered
they were
all irrelevant by that point that's a
great intervention
on her part did you look at it
afterwards or was it just
enough just enough catharsis to simply
get it out of your head and into some
recorded format
well at that moment in time it was
enough to get me back to sleep but when
we looked at it three months later
it was shocking it was incredible
i was like how is it that in our minds
we amplify
things we think that that these
challenges in front of our eyes or these
anxieties we have are so big
and so often they're not so often
they pass with time or they are resolved
or they
you know they're less important than you
think they are this is a good point to
ask you
about i think optimism because as i
understand it this
is a trait maybe trait isn't the right
label but it is a characteristic that
you've identified as one of the
meta characteristics of many successful
entrepreneurs and please feel free to
fact check this and correct what i'm
saying
could you expand on that i'm just so
curious because
you've you've interviewed so many mega
successful
entrepreneurs how consistent is this
what type of optimism is it if that
makes any sense
and how much of it is do you think is
nature versus
nurture training yeah i am a big first
of all i'm a big believer in training
this is why i'm a fan of the work you do
because you um
have trained yourself to develop
expertise in
a variety of things to prove that
anybody can do this
now i you know i do think that there are
some people who are just born
with more charisma that's a fact some
people just have it
but i wouldn't say most of the
entrepreneurs on the show
are born with that kind of charisma and
i wouldn't even say that they are
any different than the rest of us but i
do
think that they were able to convince
themselves
that their idea was going to work
i'll give you an example tristan walker
he founded this company called bevel
they make it's now owned by procter
gamble they make razors and other
products
for men and women of color and the
reason why is because
particularly you know african-american
men when they shave
oftentimes they develop razor bumps
which are painful
and scarring and really very challenging
and there were
almost no products that served black men
and tristan wanted to create something
that was beautifully packaged that was
high quality that was designed for you
know men who have curly hair
when they're so when their hair grows
back out of their beards
it wouldn't curl back into their skin he
wanted to create a razor that would
solve that problem
he could not find funding for this he
could not you know eventually found some
funding
but he really couldn't find the kind of
funding that like dollar shave club got
or
you know some of these other brands
harry's and i
asked him i said why did you when this
wasn't working when you weren't
you know able to market this properly or
get the sales you wanted
how did you know not like how did you
know to keep going
how did you have the optimism he said
because i
i knew with my heart and soul every
single man that i have known my whole
life
every black and brown man that i've
known
who has this problem needs it to be
solved and if i
can't do it nobody's going to do it if
this isn't going to work with me it's
not going to work with anyone and this
problem is never going to be solved
he said so what kept me going was i knew
this was a problem
that had to be solved and i was
convinced of it
and that's what kept him going today the
the brand is owned by procter gamble
it's
incredibly successful it's you know
targeting walmart and everywhere
around the country and tristan walker is
just a phenomenal
inspiring guy and that's the thing you
know
i think that it's not this blind
optimism
but it is an unshakable belief
that the idea they have has to be
put out it has to be out in the world in
some form or fashion it has to i mean
you know jamie simenov with ring with
his doorbell company i mean it was
he was close to bankrupt eight years ago
his wife almost took they almost took
out
a line of credit on their on their house
to save this business
um what eventually saved him was going
on shark tank
he got really lucky and went on shark
tank and got this exposure but
you know he really believed that that
people would want a video doorbell
you know he just he just in his heart
and
gut he knew it and i and so i think that
it is
you know it is a learned behavior i
think
really believing in something is a
learned behavior i think
most most of the skill most of the
traits
we call traits of entrepreneurs are not
actually
traits i think they are skills that are
learned i think
some people are naturally more inclined
to
assimilate these ideas faster but i
think for the most part
most of us have the capacity to learn
these behaviors and skills
that enable us all to behave
entrepreneurially
i want to ask you about
any of these traits that i do these
types of uh
previews of upcoming questions quite a
lot i hope it's not overly irritating
but it's a way for me to bookmark for
myself i'm going to ask you about
what traits or behaviors you have
developed maybe through osmosis by doing
these interviews or that you've actually
copy and pasted into into practice for
yourself from
these many interviews that you've done
with how i built this i just have to say
i've never shared this before but since
you've mentioned his name twice
so jamie and i met randomly the first
time
and i ended up becoming sort of a
indirect investor in ring
because we met i want to say around 2007
early days because he was staying at a
hotel in palo alto i went to the same
hotel
restaurant to have a lunch meeting and i
screwed up the day i was there on the
wrong day and we're the only two guys
sitting in this
restaurant and he's like hey what are
you doing here somehow struck up a
conversation
you know jamie's he's he's uh he's very
proactive with introducing himself super
charming guy really great guy
and i said well i showed up and
i showed up on the wrong day my my date
isn't here and he's like well do you
want to have breakfast
and so we ended up having breakfast wow
and it's it just goes to show like the
little tiny
bits of initiative add up over time
right you're just
in the case of jamie he's increasing the
likelihood i don't remember the
attribution but what someone referred to
as the surface area of luck
just the the open area upon which some
serendipity can stick
and so we became friends and ended up
doing all this stuff at the time he had
a company called simulscribe and he's
he is to your point uh certainly he's
born with with certain predispositions
but he has
practiced he has learned and practiced a
lot of these things so
can i can i add a story to that because
yeah because
he is the perfect example of this idea
that you just
put out there right which is to increase
the surface area of luck
he was at sort of the low point for his
business
doorbot it was called doorbot before it
was ring a friend of us called him up
and said hey i know this guy
he he wants to start a social media
network he doesn't really know much
about entrepreneurship and
you know he asked me if i know any
entrepreneurs and i know you you start a
bunch of businesses because
at that point jamie had started a bunch
of businesses and hadn't really
started a successful business yet and so
he calls up jamie and he says hey will
you meet my friend and
have lunch with them and jamie's like
all right fine i'll do it so the day of
the lunch comes and it's
just a horrible day for jamie like his
business is like tanking
he's feeling really low he's not feeling
confident um
he really doesn't want to go to this
lunch he he knows that this guy he's
having lunch with us actually comes from
a family of
with a lot of money and he's like why am
i going and giving him advice what
advice can i can i give this guy
and it's all the way in like hollywood
and he's got to drive from the other
side of la and
he gets to this lunch and he's hearing
the guy's idea and it's
it's not a great idea it's a social
media network for um
for hollywood agents and he asks jamie
for his feedback and jamie gives him
you know earnest honest feedback and the
guy was like oh i really appreciate that
and he's like oh by the way what are you
working on and jamie's like oh it's
nothing that's just
so gonna tell me he's like oh well it's
these doorbells called doorbot it's
like a video doorbell and it's it's you
know we're trying to
see if it'll work and he's like no way
he's like dude you should go on shark
tank
and jamie's like and jamie's like well
i'd love to go on shark tank but so
thirty thousand other people he's like
no no he's like i have a friend who's a
producer on shark tank he's like
oh he's like let me get you in touch
with him
that one lunch transformed jaime's life
you know it's it's this idea of taking
opportunities when they come and
understanding that
luck really does pass all of us by
sometimes multiple times um and it's
really what we
end up doing with it definitely i i
love that those stories are so similar i
mean
yeah so it's a practice so to come back
to the
question i promised are there any
particular habits practices
characteristics that you have developed
or tried to develop as a result of
all of these interviews that you've done
yeah um i mean a lot of them i i think
about
i think about change a lot i think about
pivoting a lot and i think about
interrogating what we do
all of the time i mean this is something
that you know howard schultz
would do with starbucks constantly
interrogate what they're doing
and really never allowing the company to
become comfortable you know to
to always um kind of stay off balance a
little bit
you know starbucks is a good example
because it's just so it's such a
behemoth
i remember herb kelleher the late herb
kelleher of southwest airlines
who um you know he didn't live in austin
but he lived in
not too far from you in texas i guess
far texas is pretty big
um but herb keller just a wonderful man
started southwest airlines and his motto
was think
small act small and that's how you get
big
and i wrote a chapter about this in the
book because what he was saying was
essentially was
don't get comfortable you know he saw
the collapse of the big airlines twa
and and aloha and a bunch of other big
airlines pan am
and he said they collapsed because they
got too comfortable and cocky and they
they were on top of the world and and so
they stopped paying attention to the
things that mattered like efficiencies
and
and and innovation and so you know he
was
his argument was let's think small let's
act small well today southwest airlines
is what the third biggest airline in the
world
right and so that to me is a really
inspiring way to think about
what we do too you know i do i do try to
think small and act small i don't ever
take for granted our
the success of our show and our
listeners in fact you know after the
pandemic hit
we had a moment where our audience
really just
briefly collapsed not collapsed it
dramatically dropped
and you know i was really concerned
about that
and i think that's true true for a lot
of people and we had this one we had
this really
true for me as well just a dramatic
decline and
it was scary and so i started to
interrogate what we were doing and
whether we could do it better
and we triple down i mean we we launched
a new
offshoot show called the how i built
this resilience series which i now do
twice a week in addition to the main
episodes
on mondays so do main episode monday and
then wednesday and friday i do a live
conversation with a founder talking
about resilience
and we you know miraculously we doubled
our audience
we really worked and continued to work
really hard on it
the other thing that you know i've been
really influenced
around is the idea of rejection i think
that this
to me is the most important
skill that an entrepreneur has to
develop the ability to withstand
rejection
rejection is really hard it really sucks
like i don't know if you ever
experienced this tim when you were
younger but you know asking somebody out
on a date
was very hard for me to do when i was
younger i would never have done it
because i was always scared of
somebody saying no i wasn't like you
know some of these people that i
remember they would say well you ask a
hundred people out and maybe one will go
out with you
um i wasn't like that i've never been
good with rejection i've learned to get
much
better with it and why this is important
is because
when you are building any idea whether
it's in your company like if you're
intrapreneurial
or you're trying to create something
disruptive out in the world
you will always find people who will
push back against it
right they're always going to be people
who will reject
your idea and it's why i think a lot of
successful entrepreneurs started out as
sales people
like mark cuban or sarah blakely you
know she was selling fax machines
door-to-door
mark cuban was selling computer software
for you know copy serve and
we eventually sold the copy server he
was he was going door-to-door
selling selling software and you know
over time you get used to people saying
no soliciting no thank you
please leave my premises or hanging of
the phone and
be becoming resilient to that and and
and just knowing that you've got to keep
grinding away
because that is essentially what a
business is about
and if you can learn that if you can
kind of expose yourself
to rejection again and again and develop
a thicker skin and ability to withstand
that in my experience interviewing now
you know deep dive interviews with more
than 300
very influential entrepreneurs i've
discovered that that is really something
that
almost all of them have in common i uh
could not agree more i
think that the the fact that that is a
not just a learnable but a conditionable
skill
if that makes sense is really really
important it's like
developing a tan or developing strength
in the gym
there's a progressive resistance to it
and
as you get stronger the weights will
feel lighter
you can add resistance you can go for
bigger targets and
what if done really infrequently might
have a large impact on you gets to the
point where
it has no impact or negligible impact
on your momentum if that makes sense
it's it's really really
important what do you think the podcast
landscape
or world will look like in two or three
years what do you think will change
if you had to put on your your
forecasting prediction hat
what do you think's going to change what
do you think it's going to look like i
think it's going to be much
closer to the premium television model
i think that we are going to see more
and more
large networks like spotify amazon
apple etc platforms i should say
kind of creating walled gardens they may
be free wild gardens
but walled gardens where you can only
hear you know joe rogan on spotify or
you can only hear guy roz on spotify or
tim ferriss
or on amazon whatever it might be i
think that is inevitable
if i be perfectly honest i don't know if
that's
going to be great for consumers and i
don't know if it's going to be great for
podcast kind of ecosystem you know
podcasting right now is a little bit
like community radio in the in the 70s
it's
wide open anybody can start one there
are a million podcasts in the english
language
only a tiny tiny you know
top of a pin head number of those
podcasts
have over 50 000 listeners a week just a
teeny tiny number and even a smaller
atomic you know molecule fraction of
that
have a million or more listeners a week
it doesn't mean that it's impossible to
gain that audience i mean the beauty of
podcasting is the barrier to entry is
very
low anybody can start recording
themselves and upload it to
to these platforms but i think that
the reality is that um it is also an
advertising platform
and where there's money to be made there
are going to be
you know all kinds of folks looking for
opportunities and there's nothing wrong
with that
my hope is that it's not only market
driven
you know because i think if podcasting
is entirely market driven
you're gonna see a lot of content that
is polarizing you're gonna see a lot of
politically polarizing content and also
a lot of um
like true crime content and i'm not
saying there's anything wrong with that
i enjoy some of that stuff
but i don't want that to be the only
thing that is rising to the top you know
i think that
there needs to be a world in podcasting
where you've got
shows that are just magical and
brilliant but also expensive i mean
radio lab is an expensive
show to make invisibilia npr's program
is an expensive show to make but they're
so beautiful and so brilliant and so
important
and so you know my hope is that you know
there will still be a world where
that content can be created without the
you know the necessity to to profit
necessarily
but i do think that the industry is
moving in that direction i think what's
going to look
more like hbo and hulu and netflix and
you know
disney plus and et cetera et cetera
where you're going to probably have to
subscribe or pay
to these different channels to hear your
favorite programs yeah you mentioned
invisibilia and these some of these
incredible shows
that are expensive to produce and to
second your sort of observation or hope
that
it's not just things that are projected
to have market appeal
right that get produced in three
years time it's it's also notoriously
difficult to predict
what there is or is not a market for
unless you're just
going with the lazy layup you know kind
of copycat stuff in a given genre
because if we take an example like dan
carlin's hardcore history
amazing show but if one were to go in
prior to the success of that show and
say you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna do
super infrequent podcasts that are
extremely long
in some cases multi-parts so it'll take
12-15 hours
about for instance uh you know genghis
khan
and we think that uh that's going to
have tremendous appeal
it wouldn't get it wouldn't get bought
no it would not get bad
which is unbelievable right you think
about it because that show is so
incredible but if you try to pitch that
today as an unknown person
yeah it wouldn't get bought and it's so
good i mean it's
so good uh so certainly
yeah i really hope it doesn't end up in
a place like you said where
the stranger out of the box stuff
doesn't have at least a
chance right a chance to
prove them wrong yeah and so
fingers crossed certainly on my side as
well what
surprised you so you have this new book
how i built this easy to remember of
course
the unexpected path to success from the
world's most inspiring entrepreneurs
a few years from now what from the book
any particular stories or lessons that
we haven't talked about that you think
are really gonna still stick with you
i mean there are a lot of them right um
but i one one that i think about a lot
you know i live in the bay area and i
used to live in the bay area
and it's a very complex place because
on the one hand you have incredible
weather and beautiful
just beautiful nature on the other hand
um you know the city of san francisco
is one of the most troubling cities in
the world you know you've got
just immense wealth the highest number
of
billionaires in the world and you've got
parts of the city that look like gotham
city you know where where
human beings are living in the most
deprived conditions
unimaginable conditions and so
with that backdrop you know i think a
lot about
san francisco and i think a lot about
what the tech world has
wrought some incredible things right
amazing transformational things but
things that have also
been so disruptive that we don't quite
we haven't fully
realized how disruptive they are
in a negative way one of the things that
i that struck me when i first moved here
because i moved to the bay area two
years ago
from washington dc was i took um
i took the ferry from jack london square
in oakland to
san francisco to the ferry terminal and
you get out
and you know there's the salesforce
tower and i think on market street
you've got like twitter and
zynga and all these huge tech companies
you know
and then like you're looking down market
street and there's
you know the headquarters of wells fargo
the world headquarters of wells fargo
and then to the right
there's like levi strauss square and
then further down there's ghirardelli
square
and i just i remember coming to san
francisco as a kid
and that was that was the city it was
like levi's and ghirardelli and
wells fargo and the transamerica tower
you know
and what's amazing is if you think about
san francisco
and you think about those enduring names
levi's
wells fargo henry wells william fargo
ghirardelli domingo ghirardelli i
started to look at into those stories
all of those people made their money
from servicing the gold rush they didn't
make their money from the gold rush
they all ended up in california because
in one summer in 1849 or 1850
30 000 people came to california from
across the country in the world
it was an invasion of human beings
searching for gold
and as we know almost nobody made
anything even sutter
ended up i believe he ended up
impoverished when he died
you know it was sutter's mill where the
gold was discovered but the people who
actually made the money
were the people like levi strauss who
sold
tents canvas tents and then jeans henry
wells and william fargo who went to
stockton
and some of these cities in central
california to
deliver help deliver packages and boxes
and that was what wells fargo was
um it was a career service you know they
they originally had started american
express and they come out to california
um ghirardelli he comes out to be a gold
prospector two but that doesn't
work out so he starts making chocolates
and pastries and
and there you go you know so i'm really
interested in this idea of
servicing big industries one of the
people i interviewed
on how i built this and i talk about in
the book is chet pipkin
chet pipkin started a company called
belkin
and i i will bet you any amount of money
that you have one of his products in
your house
and people listening to you they've got
a peripheral or a cable or
some belkin thing in their house okay
some wire to plug in your iphone
and chet pipkin really wanted to start a
pc company in the early 80s
but he couldn't compete with compaq and
texas instruments
and you know ibm and then all these pc
clones that were coming out he didn't
have the capital to do it
all he had was a soldering iron and he
knew because he was a young guy and he
used to hang out a radio shack
that if you bought an ibm pc and an
epson printer you could not
connect them because there were no
peripherals that were sold to connect
them
people initially had to have a radio
shack
sell them the different plugs and then
they would have to solder them
themselves
i mean it's nuts and he literally
started
building creating peripherals you'd buy
cables
and solder them and then sell them to
first he got his first order he sold it
to carnegie mellon
and it enabled them to connect their ibm
pcs to epson printers
well that's that became a billion dollar
business today i mean belkin
makes all kinds of peripherals and
accessories for devices and computers
so he wasn't going for the gold mine he
was
selling canvas tents and jeans to the
gold rushers you know
and today that company is is still here
and you know and you can't say the same
thing about most of those pc clones
so i'm really fascinated in looking at
a big industry when i say that
especially when i talk to younger
entrepreneurs they don't
don't try to replicate what uber's doing
try and figure out how you can service
uber
you know don't try to build the next
airbnb
build a company that actually services
things around airbnb that
is really where the that's where the
opportunities are
that is a fascinating lens to use and
you think about
say amazon and aws amazon web services
right upon which so many
businesses depend or the invisible
customer service chat companies that
white label their services to these
gigantic tech companies everyone would
recognize right and it's the plumbing
and the infrastructure and the
foundation upon which
these name brand companies rely but
their names themselves like belkin are
not
nearly as recognizable so they're
invisible
to most that is a really great way to
look at it do you have
uh any plans or any fantasies of
starting
businesses outside of the outside of the
podcast realm maybe you already have
that i don't know
yeah i mean obviously i've got i've got
a production company i've got two
so one that does how i built this and my
program wisdom from the top and and
other
you know projects around media
and i've got another production company
that makes children's content
it's called tinkercast and we make wow
in the world and um
we've got a live event series one when
there is when there are live events and
um and other projects that we do so
that's really been my main focus when it
comes to
to businesses you know they're both
small businesses but i always say to
people you know
a small business can be much more
successful than a big business you know
a corner grocery store that's profitable
is doing better than uber
let's be which is not yet profitable um
you know but it's for me i mean i often
think about i mean i think like anybody
listening to how i built this
i have a million ideas of things that i
i would love to do
and maybe i mean i love
food i love you know i've learned a lot
about cosmetics and skincare products
from how i built this and hair care
products and
i've always made things i've never
especially in the kitchen i've never
you know i don't buy mayonnaise i i
haven't i haven't bought yogurt in 20
years i'll always make it um
i i make all my own milk nut milks you
know
um kombucha i it's just things i love
doing it it's not
it sounds very npr like oh my god this
guy is an npr
person he makes his own kombucha and
almond milk but i love doing it it's
just
it's like my kids when i scream i make
it my mom used to be like that she's
like i can make it
because i love doing it you know um and
i
started to get with my wife i started to
get into uh like making
skin creams and uh and you know like
just even during the pandemic you know
because
like a lot of people i get like eczema
you know a little bit of eczema will
come up and my skin will be dry
and we just start experimenting and i sw
where do you
we have made this awesome skin cream
that i'm using all the time you know
are we ever gonna sell it unlikely but
who knows
who knows maybe the hustle
skin care for for every man and woman
if if you were to give and i know where
uh
we're probably at a point where we want
to close this round
of conversation sometime soon so i won't
chew up much more of your time but
if you were to give since you know ted
so well if you were to give a ted talk
on something unrelated or let me let me
rephrase that a ted talk on something
you are not
already known for what would it be you
mentioned cooking cast iron pots what is
what is the subject matter
that you would pick for your ted talk if
it had to be something that would
surprise most people to hear you deliver
i know a lot about
the washington nationals baseball team i
don't know if i'd give my ted talk about
that
people would not would probably would be
surprised to find out that i'm really
interested in baseball i love baseball
i'm a big baseball fan
so it could be about that i i could
probably give a ted talk
about um usually ted talks are about you
know a big idea
right so i guess my big idea
i tend to talk about them on the show
you know
kindness and things like that that i i
always aspire to
as well you know that i'm i'm sort of
giving myself
advice and looking to others for advice
too because in some ways
my show and what i do is a form of
therapy you know it's
being able to talk to people and hear
their their
challenges and dilemmas is very
therapeutic when you kind of talk
through it with somebody
and i guess my talk would be about for
me i mean i think it's
it's a hard one because i i know that it
doesn't apply to everyone and i think it
can be
maybe traumatic isn't the right word but
challenging for a lot of people to hear
but it's the one that i
i know a lot about and means a lot to me
and it's fatherhood i mean that's the
single most important part of my life
you know i i've got
two boys eleven and nine um that is my
identity first and foremost to me and
i'm a dad you know i
love everything about it i live for
my time with my kids and getting to take
a hike with them
and getting to swim with them or jump on
the trampoline or
i mean i i even i even sit and watch
their video games and i hate video games
because i just
love being around them you know and and
they're so
interesting and sometimes they drive me
crazy too but
you know like my 11 year old this this
album from juice world just came out and
he's just obsessively listening to it
because he was so sad when juice world
died and he's
deconstructing the lyrics and he's like
dad it's like he almost predicted his
own death you know and
it's just so i just love developing
those connections so for me
it's been the most fulfilling part of my
life and i think
that anybody who's lucky enough to
experience
having a child in their life will really
kind of rediscover themselves as well
and i think
that's what my talk would be about i
gotta get started on this procreation
[Laughter]
i've lost my hair you're fine some
things don't age
well i gotta i gotta get moving i think
you i think you're gonna have
you've got you're gonna have plenty of
opportunities i think there'll be lots
of people who'd be
interested i mean imagine all the things
you could teach a child to him like
you know how to you know how to ballroom
tango dance and swim and
you know across oceans and so there you
go
and i promise people i will not uh put
my child
in a skinner box any more than it's
absolutely necessary
and guy i appreciate you you're
exceptionally good at what you do you
take your craft
very seriously and you
keep yourself off balance in the sense
of continual
refinement and asking good questions not
just of your guests but of what you're
doing
and i i certainly found that to be very
clear in doing
the homework for this conversation and
i'm thrilled that you have taken
many of these lessons and learnings and
stories
from how i built this into how i built
this
uh the book itself i mean i i really
find there's a power to text
power to storytelling through text and
lest people forget i mean
you have a lot of history and practice
with storytelling through text so i'm
i'm thrilled
that you took the time to concentrate
on the new book how i built this
subtotally unexpected paths to success
from the world's most inspiring
entrepreneurs
i i imagine that it can be found
wherever books are sold
during these pandemic times and
where are the best places for people to
find you
otherwise your your preferred outlets
um the best place to find me the best
way to find the book is you can go to
guyroz.com
and all the information is there but to
find me i'm on instagram i like
instagram i'm at guy.raws
um i'm on twitter at guyroz i'm i'm on
facebook too but don't love that one
as much so um even though instagram is
facebook
but um yeah i have fun on instagram you
know i i put
personal stuff on there my kids and but
also like stuff from the show and
um and it's kind of a mixture so that i
try to just
put myself out there and um yeah so you
can find me there
well you're doing you're doing a good
job of it i don't know how
with two kids and everything you have
going on you manage
to produce as much as you do
at the quality that you do it's it's
mind-boggling to me
so that that at some point would
love to have a meal or a drink and and
try to stare into your soul and absorb
some of that that stamina and focus it's
really
i read the four hour work week that's
what i did
but just figured it out no i mean you
know it is a little bit rich for you to
be saying that because you're
insanely productive and produce insanely
good stuff so i mean this book again
it's like it's like tribe of mentors you
know it's it's designed to be a
it's designed to be a reference it's
designed to be a guide it's designed to
be the
the person that whispers in your you're
gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
keep going you know and that's that's
that's why i wrote the book
i love that i encourage people to check
it out we'll have links to everything
we've discussed in the show notes let me
ask one more question and sometimes
it's a bad question but i'm going to
risk it and that is if you could put
anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking could be an
image a word quote
something from one of the interviews
you've done anything non-commercial and
image
doesn't matter uh to
convey something to billions of people
what might you put on that billboard i
mean it's it's the
most simple thing it's the become one of
the most cliched
things too but it is so important
it's what president obama talked about
in his outgoing
address the last address he gave before
his presidency ended
and it's two words it's be kind it's be
kind i mean we are all going to be
unkind
multiple times in our lives in a day
but if you can make that your north star
and just
try and sear that into your your memory
or tattoo it on your arm
or put on a billboard it's be kind
it's gonna it's gonna make our world
just a little bit better
yeah here here be kind great answer
be kinder than you have to be and it not
only makes the world better
it makes you better and it will make you
feel better
and certainly in these these polarizing
times
where i think it's become very
fashionable and is incentivized in some
way
to be unkind that is a real
differentiator and fantastic answer so
let's
close up there anything that you would
like to
add any closing comments anything you'd
like to
to say before we bring this round one
to an end i guess i really just want to
say
that i don't believe
entrepreneurs are any different than us
i think that
we are all clark kents and the only
difference is that they went into the
phone booth
and put on the cape and and i
i'm a big believer in entrepreneurship i
think it's
exciting i think it gives people control
over their lives i think it
is good for the economy i think it spurs
innovation
um i think it allows people to to live
more independent lives and
you know we actually are not living at a
time when
entrepreneurship is at its height you
know there were more entrepreneurs in
the
70s and 80s in america than there are
today even though we talk about it more
today
there are fewer today than there were
then and i want to see a resurgence i
want to see and it's and you don't have
to
build the next earth shattering app or
you know
huge tech company it can be an hvac
company you know
it can be a small business but to me the
idea of creating something that
allows you to employ other people and
give them work and meaning
and you know a good life that allows
them to support other people
and send people to college that means a
lot i'm a really big
believer in small businesses and
entrepreneurs and
i really think that people who want to
do it the only
obstacle to getting there is the
inability to think of
oneself as an entrepreneur and what i'm
saying is that that shouldn't be an
obstacle because
everybody has the capacity to do it
indeed
and uh i want to second that
entrepreneur
if you think about the the root or even
the spanish equivalent
or the related word emprender to
undertake right one who undertakes
and how i built this i mean it really
speaks to
what it seems like you provide through a
lot of the work that you do and that is
you're offering the tools of
self-determinism right you're offering
the tools
and the stories of those who have
self-authored
and i think in times of uncertainty and
certainly
we are since you mentioned baseball i
think in
the first or second inning of lots of
uncertainty and lots of turbulence to
come in the next
year or two this is the type of
collection of stories and tools
and reassurances that can help people to
self-author
so i'm thrilled that that you took the
time to focus
and get this out to the world so thank
you guy for for taking the time
to have this conversation today thank
you so much for
for having me really appreciate it and
to everybody listening we'll have show
notes for everything that was discussed
you can find links to everything
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
and until next time
thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the the world of the esoteric
as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to
4hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by linkedin jobs
small businesses have unique needs a lot
of you know this i know this and even
with the uncertainty these days one
thing
stands unchanged and that is the
importance of having the right people on
your team but hiring can be hard it can
be really expensive if you make mistakes
very painful if you get it wrong i've
certainly had that experience i'm not
eager to repeat it so i try to do as
much
upfront screening as possible when your
business is ready to make the next hire
linkedin jobs can help you screen
candidates with the hard and soft skills
that you're looking for
they'll match your position with
qualified members so you can find the
right person
quickly using linkedin's active
community of more than 690 million
professionals worldwide
linkedin jobs can help you find and hire
the right person faster
so when your business is ready to make
that next hire find the right person
with linkedin jobs you can pay what you
want and get the first 50
off just visit linkedin.com
[Music]
tim again that's linkedin.com tim to get
50
off your first job post terms and
conditions apply
this episode is brought to you by peak t
that's p i q
u e i have had so much t in my life i've
been to
china i've lived in china in japan i've
done tea tours i drink
a lot of tea and 10 years plus
of physical experimentation and tracking
has shown me many things
chief among them gut health is critical
to just about everything and you'll see
where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health
you name it i've been drinking fermented
poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now
poor tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to
find real poorer that hasn't been
exposed to pesticides and other nasties
which is super common that's why
peaks fermented queer tea crystals have
become my daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them
through my friends dr peter attia and
kevin rose peak crystals
are cold extracted using only wild
harvested leaves from 250 year old tea
trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea
and i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a
a delicious barnyard very peaty if you
like whiskey and stuff like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic molds contaminants commonly found
in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea and that saves a
ton of time and hassle
so peak is offering 15 off their
priorities for the very first time
exclusive to
you my listeners this is a sweet offer
simply visit peakt.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners of this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is
risk free one more time check it out
peak t that's p
i q u e t e a dot com slash time
you